KENDALL ROY: I dropped a bomb.
The whole world is watching
for my next move.
GREG HIRSCH: You're
the number one trending topic
ahead of tater tots,
and the pope followed you.
-Okay, no, this is not--
-Wow.
Is this the real--
-No, I don't think
this is the pope.
-Right. Great. Thanks, Greg.
LOGAN ROY:
My family have disappeared.
I need to know where everyone is
and what everyone's thinking.
There he is, the little man
that started this big war.
Right now, I'm the real you.
Sure. And I'm the real you.
You sound deranged.
SPEAKER:
As I understand it, you want
to take down your dad
-without implicating yourself.
-Correct.
And without damaging the company
to the extent that you
lose control
at your shareholder meeting.
Do you have an actual case, Ken?
Yes, I can kill him.
Is he gonna watch?
Could we make a note
in the minutes
that he's watching us?
LOGAN: There's blood
in the water. Sharks are coming.
SHIV ROY:
We're gonna lose the company.
-We're gonna lose
the fucking company today.
-No.
TOM WAMBSGANS:
Investigation's looking
pretty bad.
I'm focused on not going
to jail.
Logan says
we have to take these.
Cyanide pills.
It's a mint, you doofus.
LOGAN:
No one's on my side in this.
I need you to protect me,
Pinky.
If we don't beef up soon,
I think we end up
someone's lunch.
-When will your father die?
-Uh...
-With due respect. Obviously.
-ROMAN ROY:
No, no, no, yeah, no.
Obviously, hugely looking
forward to my father dying.
SPEAKER 2: Right.
Where's this end? This friction?
I thought my family
was fucked up.
This is next level.
CONNOR ROY: Roman is
a knucklehead, Shiv is a fake,
and Kenny is screwy.
I've seen more than any of them.
LOGAN:
This life is not for everyone.
It's a number on a piece
of paper.
It's a fight for a knife
in the mud.
KENDALL: I'm a good guy.
I'm better than you.
We'll fuckin' beast them.
We'll go full fucking beast!
♪ ("SUCCESSION" THEME PLAYS) ♪